à cette époque il était de bon ton dans
l'aristocratie notamment de se protéger
du soleil une peau blanche et laiteuse
étant un signe de distinction
aujourd'hui les choses on vous
l'avouerez bien évolué même si certains
maintiennent la tradition mais ce ne
sont plus tout à fait des aristocrates
en tout cas pas tout à fait les mêmes
jacqueline hiver s
[Musique]
nos futurs nos browsing blanc is
beautiful tout de noir vêtu cold wave et
autre post punk sont catégoriques
haro sur les psychopathes de la crème
solaire les stakhanovistes de l'épiderme
à les aventuriers de l'extase solaire
attention les mutants sont en marche
[Musique]
on est à 80
fallout en fagots la nuque au repos pour
les branchés du vinyle taux
d'absentéisme élevé sur les plages du
sud si vous faites partie de ceux qui
s'écoute bronze et vos clopes vont
prendre une claque
je pense qu'ils sont ridicules et
je préfère être différente de et son
huile de foie c'est comme des larves qui
grouillent la toux crs blancs ça glisse
je les méprise à halimi les égouts
m'avoir la pêche pour patronyme en fait
et puis à part ça la plage
moi ça donne des rideaux françois et ça
donne des rides c'est l'homme des
cloques donne des vergetures moi j'aime
pas trop grave on l'a un peu plus malade
l'avant l'air tout kong pas l'être
vraiment peut-être qu'elle du futur
malgré tout peut être on referme l'album
live le futur est en pleine mutation
[Musique]